[Musique]
j'ai vu que tu faisais semblant de te
masturber et je me demandais si tu avais
envie qu'on en parle j'aurais aimé que
ma mère soit un gourou du sexe et si
pour commencer vous me racontiez votre
plus anciens souvenirs concernant votre
scrutin lors crois moi j'aurais détesté
il s'agit d'une nouvelle frontière mon
pote sexuelle mot refoulé c'est enfin
notre chance de remonter la chaîne
alimentaire sociale quand tu joues
m'inquiète pour toi mec tout le monde
pense à s'envoyer en l'air
ils projettent de le faire pour ils le
font pour de bon
[Musique]
les élèves de ce lycée ont besoin de toi
et on a besoin de recul je me charge du
côté commercial
et toi de la thérapie les thérapies la
thérapie sexuelle comme ta mère
sexologue dans mes t'imagines
c'est un super plan tu pourrais être
populaire il se pourrait bien que je
craque légèrement sur mech chez obsédé
par la branlette mes poils pubiens sont
déchaînés bras être un mec normal et
bien perdre avec une queue normale
partout aux deux meilleures années de
notre existence
parent
[Musique]
je vous donnais des préservatifs merci
ça va aller
[Musique]
on reste en dehors de ma vie
quelle chance tom tu veux devenir obèse
hors dom tu veux que je te viennent
mes gâteaux
on choisit pas vraiment par qui on y
attirent et tuent peut pas construire
une relation de toutes pièces
ado tu es ce que tu es ne laisse
personne te faire croire le contraire
[Musique]
je trouve toujours très bizarre qu'un
mec de tournage soit sexologue
[Musique]